so this is actually my first time
speaking and a full conference lot
there's also a couple other first time
speakers and we kind of band together to
make sure that we supported each other
and I think it's the perfect place to be
able to have my first big conference
experience this is my first time in
Iceland I've been blown away so far
everybody is so nice and it's so
relaxing here
the views are to die for one of the most
amazing things about Jess comp Iceland
is that you know accessibility inclusion
and diversity are first class citizens
and they're not something that they have
to try to do it just that's how it is
that's the culture of this conference
and even other J's conferences as well
but specifically the one in Iceland ajs
Club Iceland is just a really wonderful
conference so far I've had a fantastic
time here I had a great time which is
comp Iceland and I hope to be here
sometime in the future again
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I wanted to come to this conference for
so long I just loved this conference
I've always wanted to come to Iceland
and I'm so excited this building is just
amazing and actually all of the other
speakers are amazing I just feel really
honored to be here there was the
reception on the day we came in and then
party yesterday there's one today and
there are the trips tomorrow our thing
like if it's a conference with most
stuff going on but I've ever been to
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]